ladies and gentlemen welcome to The
Impossible series my new show where I
take seemingly impossible scenarios and
using my awesome nerve like abilities
try to make the impossible possible
today's challenge I need to figure out a
way by which along the pig man from
Dragon Ball can defeat a literal angel
in the series wheeze
so let's see if this is possible can I
find a way for lung to become the most
powerful creature in the known universe
without we stopping it all right let's
find out so I think the best way to
start this off is to explain what our
little pig friend is up against here in
other words what do we know about wheeze
and what is he capable of all right what
the hell are you explain well we have
this dated piece of information from
Akira Toriyama to go offer from before
Dragon Ball super even began where he
claimed Wiese was about 50% stronger
than beerus however that isn't much to
go on at all as since the series has
continued that figure looks to be less
and less the case and we seems like some
unstoppable monster in comparison but
for the sake of my sanity let's assume
that he is at least significantly
stronger than beerus at the very least I
think that's reasonable right and if you
thought being hugely stronger than a god
of destruction wasn't enough of an
advantage these are just some of the
reality bending abilities hulong is up
against temporal do-over grant sweets
the ability to turn back time 3 minutes
he has used this 2 times in the series
thus far the first time in resurrection
F allowing Goku to blue balls Vegeta and
the second time to put an oven mitt on
Zuma Sue's hand we salsa possesses the
ability to evade attacks and go on the
offensive without thinking what's that
called to get oh yeah Ultra instinct
which is also Omni lingual meaning he
casually understands and speaks every
language in the known universe he also
has divination which is the ability to
see events far away in time and space
basically Santa Claus master
manipulation which grants him the
ability to pass through anything he
wishes so in other words if you wanted
to he could reach into your chest and
grab your heart without making you bleed
teleporting entities as shown in the
series he possesses the ability to
teleport both Goku and Vegeta to people
he is not immediately next to or
touching from the outskirts of beerus
temple area to his bedroom and last but
certainly not least assisted childbirth
I mean it's just practical and on the
other end of the spectrum we have Lula
with the recorded power level of
ten so the brute-force approach is
looking less likely okay so what are we
sort comings and what does he week -
we've seen in the past that he can be
distracted
if either beerus or the supreme clay are
killed we speak um 'zed or menteur
inactive the super Dragon Balls are more
powerful than him
the xennos are more powerful than him el
gran D Padre probably - oh and he likes
food so how are we gonna do this well I
actually ended up doing a ton of
research for this video most of which I
can't use at all but there's my notes
now I know what you're thinking who long
should steal the dragon balls from Bulma
and wish to be more powerful than weeks
easy right only trouble is he can't do
that because the dragon balls are
limited in some form by their creators
that's why they weren't able to kill the
sands with one wish when they were
coming to earth the first time and if
Alon was to try to do that we should be
able to figure out what he was doing and
what he was up to by looking through his
staff so that's a no-go oh how about who
long ass Goku real nice to help him
gather the super Dragon Balls only
problem is the only person that can make
the wish is weeks because only certain
people know the language necessary to
communicate with the super dragon so as
you can all see this is gonna be a real
tough one but I think I have a solution
it won't be easy though it's gonna take
a lot of careful planning quick
execution and a lot of patience but I
think I have come up with a solution for
our porky friend it's really evil and
will take two years to put into action
but I think it's possible let's break it
down step one who long has to not be
[ __ ] at shape-shifting he has to be
better than quar he has to actually
train and practice I know he's capable
of it too he's transformed into an
identical copy of Bulma in the original
series of Dragon Ball
so in short hulong has to train his butt
off to become the best shapeshifter on
the planet step two once that is done he
needs to purchase the pair of panties
and some dirty magazine I know how it
sounds I'm serious it'll all make sense
in a second this is when the plan takes
place and this is where along needs to
take risks if any of the following
doesn't happen flawlessly that our
little paint friend is screwed who long
after surveying boneless place learns
where she is keeping the Dragon Balls
if the pilaf can get to it so can a
shape-shifting pig demon bent on
universe wide domination who long
shape-shifts
into a housefly he carefully bypasses
all of Bulmer security and takes the
dragonballs a small distance away from
the house not too far from capsule Corp
and that is intentional the following
needs to happen very fast and needs to
be uninterrupted in other words we need
a flawless run from here on out that
means no one interrupts is wished or
discovers what he's doing right now
Reese's attending to Goku and Vegeta or
lord beerus so he is preoccupied with
that who long then summons the eternal
dragon Shenron or shen long depending on
your dub immediately he brought out his
two wishes he wishes for the ability to
learn any language in an instant and to
know the instant transmission technique
while all of this is taking place the
sky falls dark and everyone is alerted
to the dragon summoning on earth Bowman
looks outside and notices Shenron not
too far away she makes a beeline to the
place who long is only to find him
laughing happily with some panties and a
stack of lewd magazines in his
possession she hits him and this is the
most important part moves along as
normal because she sees this as
something along would totally do step 4
wait one year and for Bobo to gather the
Dragon Balls again as normal cuz you
know she will all right so here is where
the evil part comes in you see regular
Dragon Balls along with all of their
other limitations can't bring someone
back to life if they died of natural
causes this is why guru wasn't
resurrected by the nameks
and according to Wikipedia naturally
caused deaths are defined as the end
result of an illness or an internal
malfunction of the body not directly
caused by external forces typically due
to old age okay so now it's time for my
evil plan who long now steals the Dragon
Balls after transforming into the
invisible man from fortune teller Baba's
tournament yeah who long needs to be
really good at shape-shifting here but
this is where it gets evil with a
capital e who long transports the Dragon
Balls far away from everyone and
shape-shifts from the invisible man to
Frieza he summon Shenron and as fast as
he can makes these two wishes wish
number one give all of the earth spiders
delayed onset ki disorder for those of
you out there that don't know what this
is it's an illness that
affects the key manipulation of the user
in episode 43 of Dragon Ball super
Goku suffers from it after using the
kaio-ken times 10 in the tournament
against hit he wasn't able to fly or
instant transmit with any accuracy
essentially he wasn't able to use his
powers at all and so elan will wish for
all of the Earth's fighters to come down
with a bad case of do Kady
and finally wish number 2 he wishes for
Shenron to age Bulma to the end of her
life expectancy with one minute left
blue long still looking like Frieza
shape shifts into the invisible man
again before instant transmission in
back to Master Roshi's house where he
walks into the toilet reverting back to
his long form and goes about his day as
normal
waiting for the consequences of what he
had just wished for by the time Vegeta
and Goku learn of bomas fate after
recovering from that ki disorder it will
be too late to do anything about it
temporal do-over or not however a huge
problem you might think arises wheeze
can check the past to see what happened
right but this is why I had move along
shape-shift
to the invisible man and then to Frieza
when he did what he did
Vegeta enraged and saddened will do
anything in his power to bring Bulma
back to life he suggests going to the
new planet namek to use the namekian
Dragon Balls
who long wanting to be involved in this
says that she was one of his oldest
friends and wants to help in whatever
way he can together they travel with
goku t' anomic where they will try to
wish her back using the namekian Dragon
Balls only to find out that they can't
do so because she died of natural causes
giving the cast one final option the
super Dragon Balls which leads us to the
final step of this terrible evil plan
step 5 along with Wiese beerus goku
vegeta and all those that wanted to help
who long accompanies the group to xenos
world goku pleads his case and asks for
the xenos to help he tells him that his
oldest friend in the world has died and
that the only way to bring her back
would be with the super Dragon Balls
they agreed to help and make all the
necessary arrangements to gather all of
the super Dragon Balls either Champa had
been gathering them again or they need
to start from scratch either way there
will be an adventure involved
fast-forward some time and all the super
Dragon Balls have been gathered we speak
ins to summon the dragon from the super
Dragon Balls while speaking the ancient
language of the gods while everyone is
looking at the super dragon being
summoned who belong at the back of the
group transforms into Zeno and instant
transmissions to the front of the group
standing beside Wiese this only has to
cause confusion for a split second who
long having heard the language being
spoken by Wiese now knows that language
thanks to his earlier wish with the
Earth's Dragon Balls and just like the
first wish in the series in early Dragon
Ball he blurts out still as Z no
shouting in that ancient language I wish
I was more powerful than Zeno in their
confusion who long snaps his fingers
sort of like Thanos turning back in to
along and kills Wiese in an instant dead
and that's what I think it would take
for too long to defeat Wiese what do you
guys think do you agree with my theory
or do you have a better one let me know
down below don't forget to leave a like
in this video and if you guys have
suggestions for other topics in this
impossible series be sure to leave them
down below too if you guys would like to
support my patreon the link is in the
description and until next time guys
thank you so much for watching
[Music]